dot com slash book tv
next a former baltimore homicide
detective and an investigative crime
reporter take an in-depth look at
murders in baltimore maryland which
average around 250 a year
this is about 45 minutes
yeah hi thank you for coming tonight we
um very much appreciate it uh you know
one of the reasons that kelvin and i
decided to write this book together
which of course having a reporter and a
cop writing a book together is obviously
an odd thing to begin with because you
know a relationship between reporter
club is not always
we not always see things eye to eye but
part of the interesting
point yeah
yeah yeah we're the pencil necks but
anyway the the point of it was to
to sort of get out of the cycle of
of understanding of homicide and murder
in baltimore which is difficult because
the media and the way the media is
structured crime is a very sort of uh
dramatic uh and and ongoing story in
baltimore but we don't really take the
time to look at it from a perspective of
you know it's not immediate like at this
particular moment let's try to
understand it and the reason we did that
is is fairly simple
um baltimore is consistently one of the
most violent cities in the country
no matter what i mean right now the
mayor will tell you
that crime is down and that's true but
if you look at us relative to other
cities we are the most one of the most
violent i think in the top five i don't
know exactly so the question is why and
the question is why do we keep doing the
same things i mean
in baltimore city for the past 10 years
20 years as long as i've been a reporter
you know the answer to that has been
some form of law enforcement we had the
zero tolerance policy where we arrested
100 000 people a year so it's always
been sort of a question of law
enforcement or a question of building
more prisons and and it's ironic that
you know kelvin i worked on this
together but you know my thought my
thinking was when i approached him and
we talked about doing this or he
approached me actually was to provide
some context you know was to take these
cases starting with a particular and the
details and try to invent some sort of
understanding of why baltimore has such
a penchant for murder
and that's not an easy question
but rather than be overly philosophical
you know kelvin was able to share with
me
cases and his insight into some cases
that are fairly extreme which is what
the story of crime is in baltimore
singularly which is that it's a
laboratory of the extremes you know you
have extreme behavior some of the cases
that kelvin worked on are just difficult
to comprehend when a 14 year old child
you know shoots a woman he doesn't know
from 100 yards across the street
or you know a group of teen girls set a
man on fire while he's alive
you know these are things as citizens of
the city
that are difficult for us to comprehend
but must be comprehended in some way
that's meaningful
so that we can perhaps alleviate this
problem i guess would be the
what i was looking for you know i i i
cover crime as a reporter and i'm part
of the problem i mean i i go to a a
crime scene write a story interview a
few people uh now i'm a producer for fox
45 and you know part of the problem is
it's just a 24-hour news cycle so we
were hoping that this book by combining
both of our perspectives would add
something to the equation of our
understanding of crime and and what it
means why do people kill i mean you have
to think about it we're a fairly unique
city in that six or seven hundred times
a year someone picks up a gun and aims
it at someone and pulls a trigger and
that doesn't include you know stabbings
or people who die from overdoses and
undetermined deaths which are
unclassified you know it's a quite
unusual compared to any other city in
this country besides detroit and a few
others compared to europe and other
places you know we in many times in many
social situations choose violence to
settle matters that might otherwise be
settled you know in less violent ways so
the question is what are the combination
of of factors you know what is it in the
psyche of the people who choose to take
another life and the only way really
you're going to know that is from
someone like kelvin who has sat in the
box with people has been uh up close to
people who we would consider most of us
consider
have done things that would be
absolutely reprehensible to us but
however seem commonplace
so um
that being said you know kelvin maybe
you want to talk a little bit about why
you decided to participate in this or
why we did this together but first off i
wanted to say that the book also talks
about how difficult the homicide
detective's job is working here in
baltimore city guys go out each and
every day they experience um
some of the difficult difficult
challenges dealing with families who who
have lost loved ones these guys
sometimes have
ladies and gentlemen sometimes have to
put their families second to deal with
the families who lost loved ones to
bring closure to their lives so
um
these detectives including myself at one
point in time we spent a lot of time in
what we call the box that's the energy
room down to baltimore city
a homicide unit we we deal with some of
the most violent criminals some of us a
lot of repeat offenders
and uh we try to to do sometimes the
impossible get confessions out of why
they
done some of the things they've done
taken take another human being's life
sometimes it's difficult challenge
sometimes
uh a person
just do it out of for example
love for another i would say a love
hate for another person
um one of the cases particularly
is the case with melvin wilson i wanted
to talk about who in fact thought he was
in love with a 14 year old a
nine-year-old kid i'm sorry irvin harris
um urban i guess to melvin portrayed
betrayed his love
by wanting to buy a young girl who lived
in the neighborhood a gift because of
that for some reason melvin snapped in
and lured the little kid up into the
woods and took his life and that was
difficult because
a lot came out of that case where's
social service was involved in this case
where the mother was worn several times
to have this person stay away from her
kid the mother herself wound up going to
jail
for not protecting her kid the way she
should have like she should have so um
also the case of melody smith who we um
who
the police department repeatedly
received calls to come to a house and
dealing with a person by the name of
gregory tierson he uh kind of lured the
police officers away from ms smith and
directed
the police officers towards him to show
that he was the victim and not melody
smith in the entire time it was melody
smith and in fact
i think the police officers responded to
her house at least 50 times before we
were relocated miss smith on the couch
for chair strangled and beat to death
in fact at one point
while we were at the location
while we were at the location miss
smith helped us out in her case by
fedexing herself a letter indicating who
the suspect was who killed her and that
letter arrived at her residence while we
were there that day
and that that's that's also
one of the things that we discussed in
this book right here yeah i mean one
thing is that kelvin
we talked a l quite a bit during his
time when i was reporter and he was a
homicide detective one of the things
that he
let me know is how dysfunctional the
system was in many cases like in the
case of miss smith who you know had
filed a protection order and called the
police 50 times and also the situation
you had with the state's attorney's
office where many times you know kelvin
would say look i i know who did this i
know who murdered this person
and i have a witness but i don't have
two witnesses so the state's attorney's
office will not issue a warrant
and this became a big issue in the
campaign with miss jessamy versus our
current state's attorney greg bernstein
but to me it was
i mean you get a call from kelvin he
says look i i could put take a murder
off the street right now
but i can't get a warrant
and to me that spoke to uh you know
dysfunctionality in the system that we
as citizens of baltimore pay a great
deal of money to protect us
and that oftentimes seems lost in
politics and
and you know a lot of the other
things that shouldn't really infect an
organization that's trying to take
murderers off the street there should be
some sense of priority
but you know um and that was a that was
a big problem and i see a lot of
homicide detectives around in the
audience right now who they can also
understand what we we've been through
now on the floor homicide with we have
suspects out there walking the streets
right now that we know should be off the
streets if we had a little bit of help
from
uh
then the state's attorney's office but
now we got as you say greg bernstein
who's in office right now who vote let
us take any cases uh these cases to
court with these one witnesses and try
to get these people prosecuted off the
streets but for homicide detectives very
frustrating because you know a person
committed a murder you could talk to
that person you talk to that person
while he's on the street you know he he
did this murder but you don't have you
don't have the the tools to take him off
the street because that lies with
someone else and i think
um
to some extent that's not fair to the
detectives who work hard out there
trying to get these murderers off the
street
what was the thing you should say to me
about the building
about
what to call me up all the time and say
what do you say uh when i'm driving into
work coming out while driving my vehicle
down to fayette street i would look up
at the building
a police headquarters i always say you
know
i called steve one time you know there's
more problems in that building right
there than it is on the street
you know
so we so
if we can just get the building straight
first maybe we can help the people a
little bit better out there on the
streets of baltimore city and i think
it's you know for both of us when we you
know calvin has to go to the homes of
people whose
son or daughter has been taken from this
world and as a reporter we also had
talked to those families and you know
when you see
all the sort of obstacles to clear
thinking and truth with regards to the
subject matter um it becomes frustrating
i think that's one of the reasons the
book was so important was at least give
the people in the city a clear
straightforward
um you know unobstructed view
of what happens and and and why people
might kill and maybe start to answer
that question and if we can answer that
question then we perhaps have
the ability to solve the problem you
know which is really has been beyond our
ability you know i was just looking at
the murder rate in dc they've had 45
murders this year as opposed to 125 or i
don't know exactly this year in the city
and that is true throughout the country
so why should we have to suffer with the
worst homicide rate
uh or one of the worst homicide rates
and i think part of the problem is just
that we don't really have time or we
don't really know
exactly what's going on and we can't
deal with the situation if we don't have
some sense of the truth and kelvin was
really courageous enough and and and
and
willing to share that so that i could
write it in a way or we could write
together in a way that would be
meaningful so you know that's why we did
the book i think we want to just let
people on
basically what this book is also is
about is
there's no editing in this book which it
tells about the truth of what goes on in
the streets of baltimore city it doesn't
give you that challenge 11 channel 13 or
channel 2 news version of it gives you
the grimly details of what actually
occurring on the streets of baltimore
city i think people should should unders
should get this they should
they people people want to know the
truth they don't know what goes on this
book tells the truth it tells what
actually happens out there it takes it
takes away from the the uh
what the news put out this is the grimly
details were actually having some people
to stop and think this is what happens
in baltimore city so what are we going
to do about it to try to uh fix this
problem
okay yeah i mean i don't want to i mean
and also just one other comment in terms
of the the media i'm a member of the
media and i work currently for fox 45 as
an investigative producer so i i think
that the media is structured an
important way to get breaking news and
fast news this is not a condemnation
it's it's more saying that you know we
everyone deserves some time to think
about things this book is supposedly a
more thoughtful look at it than an
immediate look at it so um you know i
spent a lot of time with kelvin
discussing the cases and he gave me a
lot of insight and that's more what it's
about so and also to watch it to watch
your loved ones a little bit better but
by reading this book it it it shows you
these uh
uh
in the individuals out there who are
committing these murders and what
they're looking for and how they commit
these murders just to keep to keep an
eye on your kids a little better keep an
eye on your loved ones a little better
so they can't become victims of homicide
and that's what this book basically to
uh talks about
can i can i make a comment here yeah
um uh
these guys would sen sent material to me
most often in the middle of the night in
uh in in pretty much finished draft form
and i had to read it and i this is
something that i think everybody needs
to read
i couldn't put it down and i don't like
to read crime stories i don't i don't
want to read about murder and and what
happens to people but every time i read
a draft i couldn't put it down it was so
compelling and kevin's perspective on on
what goes on in baltimore and what goes
on in the police department is something
that everybody in baltimore and other
places need to know about because it
needs fixing and and
hopefully this this book or that their
his intention and steven's intention um
is is to to hopefully do something about
this um not that we can solve those
problems necessarily but uh we do we do
run uh on investigative voice stephen
and i
run lots of stories about crime and
about murder and about shootings and it
seems like every week somebody's being
shot somebody's being killed in
baltimore and it's it's a horrible thing
but we can't close our eyes to it and
say well i don't want to deal with that
i don't want to read about it it's
something that we all have to deal with
that we live here we tried
we tried as closely as possible to get
into the
the
psyche of the person that calvin
encountered and some of the people in
the cases and and what he shared with me
in the box so hopefully you know the
book itself will give you that
perspective that perhaps a homicide
detective would have and thus
give you a sense of how sort of
disassociated certain parts of the city
are with the rest of the city i mean it
you know as a reporter i go to the east
side and the west side and it's like you
know you're going into it a place where
you know 30 people 40 people have been
murdered in a year within you know very
small area and it transforms the
psychological landscape of the city
because people are you know i was just
interviewing someone today and he said
well you know the people who uh who who
are really transformed by violence they
don't blink because if they blink uh
they might get killed so they become
very tense and he was just talking about
dealing with kids who had witnessed
three four or five murders by the age of
nine or ten and it's transformative on
your psyche you know because you have
been surrounded by violence that is
almost like a war zone
and so the nature of those neighborhoods
the lack of support and community
services and the things that you know
give the neighborhood stability uh are
hard to describe you know unless you see
it firsthand i think kelvin has seen it
you know first hand
definitely i've seen it
seeing it firsthand definitely
definitely put an impact on on
on why i wanted this book to come out i
wanted people to understand and see what
i
did through my eyes without what i've
seen
um so they can basically just be careful
but honestly i also wanted to say that
to turn this society around and get
these people to start thinking about um
protecting their their loved ones you
got to start with it you have to start
with these elementary schools you know
to start at that level um by the time a
kid turned 15 years old 16 years old in
that middle school age a lot of times
they some they could still be saved but
if you thought if you get them at the if
you get them at the elementary school
age and work with those kids to try to
turn these kids get these kids
on a straight narrow at that point i
think our society would change in the
near future
okay we can um
bank is going to matter if any people if
anyone wants to ask questions um
oh i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry um this is
al forman he edited the book for us um
he was very instrumental in helping us
put it together and uh he was a great
part of what we did together created the
one who said everybody should read it
right yeah
yeah
i guarantee if you read this book uh
you're gonna you're not gonna want to
put it down there's a lot of information
in this book that people need to know
and i
think that it's gonna help a lot of
people understand what really goes on
here in baltimore city ben's gonna see
we get some questions yeah we'll have
about uh
10-15 minutes of q a and then uh at the
end of that uh we have copies of the
book on sale in the back and i'm sure
these gentlemen will be glad to
uh discuss further the book with you and
end or sign a copy of the book for you
um and we'll obviously be open and the
bar in the back will be open again if
you want to get another refreshment or
something so
that being said who has comments are
questions yeah i'm just wondering if you
guys can talk about some of the
conclusions of why people kill
i mean that's the title and and you know
there's i have that question and then
also um the idea of
this book giving a lot of details about
homicide murder and
you know what goes on behind the scenes
i feel like um
there's a lot of
unnecessary information in the media
daily it's not just weekly it's every
night about who gets killed and what
happens and it's very salacious and you
know people kind of glom onto that so
what's the difference between that and
what's in the book so i know those are
two questions but
um well first of all you know the
the difference in this book perhaps is
the intimacy of the of the narrative you
know i think a lot of times in the media
we don't have time to explore
you know the character of someone behind
a crime or their personality or
this or the social circumstances or the
context you know i mean
why people kill in baltimore to me
and this is just simply from talking to
people and going these neighborhoods
is because a lot of times they feel
that's the only choice
that they have you know that their lives
you know they're so separate from the
system that we all are used to
participating in in a lot of ways you
know i mean
uh you know i was talking to this young
gentleman today and he was saying you
know they don't
they don't think people in some of these
communities don't believe that they have
a few the same future that most people
have so when a conflict arises
uh you know it's easier to pick up a gun
maybe or the frustration the anger and
isolation you know i'm i'm not making
excuses for people who decide to do this
but i'm simply telling you what you know
i've learned from talking to calvin and
from going to neighborhoods that there's
a sense of isolation and desperation
that is inculcated into their lives to
an extent that it's the only reality
that they know you know or that this
particular person knows and it
transcends all the type of decisions
that we make in our lives to deal with
things that we can't deal with we all
reach walls and places where we and we
have places to turn but i think in a lot
of these neighborhoods the rec centers
have gone you know the schools are are
having trouble there's a tremendous
police presence but there's not a
presence that says well we have a way to
help you or we have a way to show you a
future where you know your life will be
improved you know there's lead poisoning
you know their apartments today was an
apartment a woman was living next door
she was paying 800 rent for for for a
row home they were home next door had
been abandoned
and the landlord just boarded up the
next person there was cockroaches were
so bad she had to throw out all her
furniture
and everyone she called
wouldn't help her
she called the health department so
there's a sense of isolation and that
isolation i think leads to desperation
but you know i can't i'm not saying that
that they that they did the right thing
or this is a moral justification for
taking someone's life but i'm i'm simply
trying to answer the question in a way
truthfully this is what does it a lot of
times when you say that you say well
look at the circumstances look at people
say well that's ridiculous you're a jerk
how can you say something so ridiculous
it's their choice and that's true but if
we ignore the factors if we ignore
um what type of community we've created
uh then we're just gonna be in the same
we're gonna be having the same
conversation three years from now one of
the key elements of this book is we call
it why do we kill not why do they or you
or someone else but we because we as a
community i think share a certain amount
of responsibility for everything that
occurs
and until we really recognize that on a
fundamental and
and complete level we're not really
going to be able to solve this problem i
mean if people think it's wrong to say
um that we have created this then we
will i guarantee you four years from now
have just as many murders as we have
this year i guarantee you until we're
willing to say well collectively we have
created a world where there are haves
and haves not to such an extreme that
people feel hopeless until we're willing
to acknowledge that uh we'll never
really understand the psyche of the
killer because it's not just like all
these people are the serial killers you
see on tv who live in a duplex apartment
and create
incredible that was the thing i learned
so much from calvin was he would talk
about these people it wasn't like um one
of the killers you know was like
something it was nothing like i've ever
seen in a narrative or or a fictive tv
thing it was just matter of fact you
know melvin jones said well he was
cheating on me
now he was a 50 year old man and and
irvin harris was nine
you know or did i get the names wrong
i'm sorry that's right okay yeah and so
you know
so it's like it was a matter of fact it
wasn't like he'd been putting up
pictures of them all over his wall and
had you know a helicopter and uh and put
them in the basement and put costumes on
them it's not like that
not at least in the world from what i
understand right it's correct okay let's
make sure
so you know
we have to get past that narrative and
to get past that narrative is to to look
at it collectively it's our community
so
you touched on the despair that that
people feel there are many studies that
are there have shown that
kids growing up in the inner city
particularly african-american boys
don't expect to live to be 20 years old
so if you don't expect to live to be 20
then then what is there to restrict you
from doing whatever you need to do to
survive as long as you can tell them
about that that's what they do what you
do
what's the alphabet oh
one of the techniques that i use and
some of my detectors in the back might
smaller this um
uh we get those the hardened criminals
inside what we call the box the
interview room and they don't want to
talk to you you try to try to get a
sense of what where where this interview
was going and they sit back and they
lean back in the chair and the first
thing actually my eyes i was telling
okay well
you know you you're so tough she's so
you're so bad
recite the alphabet
you'd be surprised with the education
system we have here today that a lot of
people don't even know that the the the
english language of the alphabet nobody
knows it i don't know the alphabet and
that's what helped me start to break the
ice and start the conversation with them
they can't say i don't don't give me the
elemental p take your time and say abc
because i get that a lot now and then
people can sing it i want you to say it
but and that breaks the ice and that's
what you get try to come down to how can
i say their level and then start talking
to them and sometimes a lot of
guys or individuals in the bathroom they
talk to you and sometimes they don't but
most of the time some of the tactics
that we use in homicide we get our point
across and they talk to us about why
they committed this myriad of why they
did it or how they did it and that's and
that's what we try to accomplish when
we're in the box and get some of these
cases solved
that's one of the best stories in the
book you have to read
more about it in detail yes
the credo local newscasting has been for
years if it bleeds it leads
but when i watch local television news
in baltimore i have never seen as much
emphasis on violence as today not only
one or two stories but four or five
stories one afternoon another so the
question is
do we have more violence than we used to
have is a different kind of violence or
is this just a function of news policies
well i mean that's a really good
question and um you know i think if you
look at the numbers technically we have
fewer homicides than when you're a
reporter at the sun
you know we probably had 350 at that
point right or 300 maybe the 90s i'm not
sure but the reason
and i don't know what the reason
particularly this phenomenon is but
crime gets more hits on the internet
and as companies as companies media
companies you know sort of transform
from print to
if you write a crime story versus a
story about a city city council
municipal hearing the crime story will
get four or five times as many
reads as a story about you know who
passed the most recent bill on whatever
and that dictates decisions made in
media companies because you know
internet advertising is based primarily
off of um you know how many hits you get
that's
you know the very straightforward answer
now why crime has become an obsession
you know could it be the wire we've been
wirefied and we are you know a city that
is best known for exporting misery you
know and that's become maybe our
cultural product is the fact that we
produce a lot of crazy crime stories
that go viral over the internet that
become national stories you know we're
maybe that's part of it maybe it's it's
the fact that
people just feel like this problem has
lingered so long that it requires all
our attention and the thing is true also
in the middle of the decade i mean
mayor martin o'malley politicized the
issue and said you know baltimore city
will not be whole until we reduce crime
and i will reduce the homicide rate and
so it became crime became purely
political and numbers became political
and so everything came down to what are
your numbers is crime lower is crime
higher so of course the media can't
resist
when when a politician is proven wrong
when crime continues and homicide
continues to expose that story it's
almost like baiting them saying you know
i'm going to reduce homicide under 200
we all remember that the beginning of
the decade that became and that affected
how kelvin did his job
so
when you politicize something like crime
then you make it a currency that you
know the media just can't resist and it
becomes the whole story you know i mean
that's why i think and what i don't want
people in baltimore city is to accept is
at the end of the year with we we have
200 for example last year 230 223
homicides you know don't accept that
because all on the back of my mind i
always thought the one homicide was too
many so you you brag on you brag on 220
and 230 homicides when you shouldn't
have won
but that's just the way society accepts
things these days and we hope we're
trying to change that the way people
think
another question
yes um is there any sort of european
like
thing that makes baltimore special than
other regional cities or
other cities of the same uh
racial breakdown that makes like
homicides go up
though
mostly makes baltimore unique
what makes it
rates based on the homicide rate you're
talking about i'm saying what what what
about this city in particular drives
this rate that other cities around don't
have
or might not have the same
well
it's a [ __ ] i think i'm trying to
understand your question basically well
you know he's basically you know does
what makes baltimore unique is there
anything that makes baltimore unique in
terms of why our homeless that informs
our homicide rate you know well if you
drive to baltimore city especially on
the east side of baltimore on the west
side of baltimore you're going to see a
lot of abandoned homes we're the future
for the kids and with the look at the
education system itself i put people in
the box i asked them to say the abcs
they don't know it
so the education system i think needs to
be better and and a lot of people living
on the streets these days so they're
trying to they're trying to do the best
they can i'm not i'm not um
i'm not trying to explain i'm not trying
to
make it right what they're doing because
it's not right but you gotta you gotta
educate the people a little more and
that's why i say start with the start
with the elementary system because a lot
of these guys are in middle school in
high school all the kids are already
affiliated with games
and it's just like the bounty hunters
itself most of the kids who committed
that crime and set pedro taylor on fire
while he was still alive was 15 and 16
years old he's the p they were kids who
were who were in middle school
elementary school you have to we have to
do something to try to educate these
kids that these things that they're
doing is not writing is wrong but it
starts in it it starts at the elementary
level and not the middle school and high
school though because i mean if you can
save some at
those
those grades that's fine but you got to
get to the young kid let them know that
that you can be whatever you want to be
in life but you're going to have to
start right here most of the kids that
that are going to a lot of these middle
schools and and
and uh high schools
their thought process all ready to join
the game and be affiliated with the game
because that's the only family that they
have i think um just to expand upon that
baltimore is a grand
experiment from my perspective in social
isolation you know as as policy you know
everything is extreme in baltimore
whether it be property taxes car
insurance you know
everything and the idea somehow seems to
be that we can isolate baltimore and and
keep those problems from seeping into
baltimore county or howard county and i
mean maybe it's very similar to the
social patterns of you know suburbanism
but really baltimore has tried to do
things and say we can put people in a
certain spot we'll make them poorer less
educated you know sicker
and it'll all work out because they'll
be there and we'll be here
and so i think baltimore has has tried
to do this to the extreme that you've
created a situation where you know
murder and violence is is the obvious
outcome of that type of experiment and i
think that's what makes i mean i'm not
saying there are other cities like that
i perhaps detroit
uh but you know i'm from new york and
that that really new york was a little
different in that regard there was more
of a sense that the city you know
was self-sustaining in the city was
important in baltimore some some of the
thesis seems to be when you write
stories that baltimore is is supposed to
fail
it is is it is designed to veil and when
you write a story about its failure
everyone reads and says great you got it
right thank you for writing that story i
told you this wasn't going to work and
so it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
it's a setup
and
we sit there and we look at the violence
say this is crazy four people shot in 24
hours well maybe this is the outcome
that's supposed to happen maybe this is
what happens when you design a city to
be isolated part of it to be isolated
from the other part you know and when
you don't have a full community you
should i'm sorry
yeah
that gentleman had a question to them
before
i think the book's a fantastic read to
be honest it's a really good book
i think you captured uh the inside of
this mother very very well
my question is is there a um
any plans for yourself
i get that question all the time i'll
tell you
um
i i got that question again seven
o'clock this morning on email but the
thing is um we stephen and i talked
about it and we we're going to look into
it but this first book took about two
years to write
so but we're going to be that's going to
explore that option yeah and we'll we'll
decide that in the near future almost
everybody that writes into investigative
voices asked that question when's the
next book coming out and they have they
haven't read this one yet but there it
is
yeah
my question was how do you turn that
around and i do understand catching
catching
young people at an early age
but how do you turn that around in um
well i think
what you the best way to do is dissolve
the border of baltimore city and make
baltimore a part of maryland and that
would be a big part of changing make
everybody deal with the consequences of
of what we've created in baltimore and
then if you did that and and it affected
other people's lives significantly you
had the money and the power to change
things well then i think you'd see
change um i think you see real
substantial change you know rather than
creating this system walls in isolation
you know make everybody accountable and
then you know i i'm sure that's not a
palatable and probably never happened in
our lifetimes but i think once you align
the interests of the entire community
with this small part of the community
you'll see substantial changes as long
as we can isolate people and we can
write crazy stories about horrific
murders and create this you know virtual
wall
it won't change but once people are
accountable and granted maryland pays a
lot of taxes to
to you know maryland as a whole supports
baltimore city but it's it's you know
go downtown
what used to be you know a manufacturing
center is now a center of prisons and if
you you know i took a philosopher named
outlangus on a tour and he didn't he was
like i can't believe how many prisons
you have right off of 83. it goes on
forever it's human warehousing you know
that's what we do now so when we decide
that that's not effective and when we
decide politically that's not what we
want to do with the people in our city
that we want to house them or somehow
segregate them then things will change
but until then nothing will change
nothing
i i just think you gotta get i have to
be a better rehabilitation center i'm a
system in place we used to always say in
baltimore city that we're going to take
the problem and push it into baltimore
county but you get any pushes in
baltimore county now because the murder
rate is getting high out there too so we
got to deal with it here so
basically i just i just think it should
be something the system put in place
within baltimore city our own society
here to try to stop these murders
yes just say i think um
part of the issues that we have are that
we're really narrow-minded in our
approach to responding to people and
their problems
so
i agree that youth as young as we can
get them we need to be responding to
them but it's not just the youth it's
everyone else in their lives who we
sometimes you know we need to be working
with
and i just hope and i'm i don't get the
impression from anything you're saying
but i hope we're really clear that this
is about class
this is this has very little to do with
race this is about class and lack of
resources
yes well
uh
it does to a certain extent although you
know if you look at the statistics you
know in the prison system you know
african americans are more affected by
violent crime more likely to be
incarcerated and live in areas with
environmental
um
concerns so
i mean yes it's class but race has
always been a backdrop or important
story in this city you know we have
sergeant louis hopson who fought
discrimination in the baltimore city
police department and that was a very
major landmark lawsuit so
it's it it's definitely part of that
issue but you're right that you know
poor you have poor people who are
suffering more and and and poor people
who are getting killed more and poor
people so that that absolutely is true i
still think race is an important uh
issue here yeah and um getting um
to that point of reaching kids
right here in baltimore city they have
closed down the powell centers they have
closed rec centers they
they've closed a lot and and people
really don't understand the importance
of grabbing kids whenever young as
working in a pal center before
you know i had i was working with 17
year olds
that were reading on a fifth grade level
so
it's not it is a thing about race and
particularly they target the young black
males in baltimore city and until we
raise our voices and start to to try to
do something about that with these
politicians force them to do their job
i don't really see
really a a lot changing
questions sure
how do you take a situation where you
have uh kids growing up in poverty and
they see all around them some of the
largest of the baltimore community you
see the big hotels in the inner harbor
you see the condos in in canton and
highland town and other parts of the
city and to say to them
uh
you can have this how do you how do you
make them believe they can have that
without becoming drug dealers and living
a life of crime because that's the way
they see to get it they see that the
drug dealers and uh and and and the
gangsters are the ones that have all the
money in their in their community so how
how do you do that
that's another point i just still going
back to
really the youth we and and really
parents but i know we're dealing with a
lot of
parents that are not doing their job but
you know i i see
when i was on uh obama city police
department everybody want to point at
the police everybody want to point at
churches everybody want to point at
schools and yes
there is a problem there
but we have to go back and educate
some of these young parents and like i
said it was starting within that pal
center i worked in that center
and i actually worked with some of those
kids and they saw a difference you know
sometimes and i told them i'm a project
i'm a a product of a project kit so you
don't have to get out here and sell
drugs to be able to uh afford a halfway
decent house
a car or something like that you know
they have to see sometimes unfortunately
positive images
outside their homes and they shut down
again like i said we had police officers
working in the palace centers where we
really cared about these kids
and worked hard you're a good example
that how did you come out of that and
and whereas most of the others can the
project's at a different time and
everybody look at the projects of a
different era projects back then was
just for low-income families i had my
mom and my dad there okay i had a father
that let me know you had a support
system right my sister i mean i had nine
brothers and sisters so
i mean and i mean it was difficult but
we understood you had to get out here
and work you didn't go out here robbing
people you didn't go out here doing this
you didn't go out here doing that that's
a good question
i mean uh uh sergeant
will tell you in in the in and you read
it in the book about the the uh the the
girls who who killed petro taylor the
one girl was this was a college student
in atlanta and her mother was a
supervisor i believe the social security
administration believed that she was
wouldn't believe him when he called to
to tell her that her daughter had just
come
confessed to murder he says can't be my
daughter my daughter's in college in
atlanta she's not even in baltimore and
and and that
is that i actually had to put up her
daughter on the phone she let her
daughter say that she's here in
baltimore she did commit to murder and
then she still didn't believe it
yeah right okay uh you had a question
yeah uh calvin you did you you you
talked about starting as the elementary
school yes and these two ladies talked
about even earlier but could you
consider the fact that if you've got a
parent that isn't prepared to raise a
child
and if the most important period of life
for the child is eight months to two
years and then from two years to six
years so we don't have kids that get are
ready for school and we don't have
schools that are ready for the kids that
somewhere back at the very beginning is
maybe maybe before elementary school is
where we have to start
and i understand that without good
without good parents don't that age
period you spoke about is going to be
difficult for the kid but once that kid
going to elementary school level it has
to be something put in place in an
elementary school system to help that
kid get a better understanding of the
things that that's happening out here is
wrong and he can make a better life for
the better way for himself but those
things i believe
based on what i i've seen expert is not
in place at this time
two more questions we'll go to you and
then uh somebody
yeah
you know i agree with calvin but i want
to go a step floor it begins at home
you know the family structure is not the
same as it was 20 years ago
you know we need to
you know we need to get back to some
basics
you know you have a kid that's in the
fifth or sixth grade who's seen violence
since they were three
and then you put them in school and you
tell them all these marvelous things of
what you can achieve and what you can
have
but that's not tangible to them because
they're going back to that environment
where they're saying mom dad sister
brother
abuse one another
abuse illegal substance
yes
uh girl you wanna talk
now i just wanna go back to um i
understand what you're saying um the
mentality of the kids for example um
the
the the 14 the uh the kid
the 14 year old who shot the lady you
know that the mentality was always set
in this kid's mind that some of the
things they he was out there doing what
was the norm for him um when i when i
interviewed that kid in what we call the
box that kid was
it took and he held out i got to give it
to the kid he held out a long time up to
maybe i was tired of maybe two to two
thirty three o'clock in the morning
finally i looked in the cellar and he
dropped his head and said let's go again
and finally
that kid looked up at me 14 year old kid
and said okay mister i did it can i go
home now but that's the this is what
this kid this is what this is known he
thought when he committed that this
murder he shot this lady
in the back of the head on a dare
um he can go home after that and he
didn't even know her he didn't know the
lady yeah hard thing to understand i
think part of the problem too is just
really quickly that we
you know we see things that have been
crystallized over you know decades and
we see a snapshot in a crime you know
and we don't always get the perspective
uh of what led up the culmination of
things that led up to that
that crime so let's go to the next one
you got a question yeah i just wanted to
ask um how long have you been homicide
detectives and also
what is possibly the most uh gruesome
case you came
uh across one
um i've been a baltimore city police
officer for 22 and a half years i've
been a homicide supervisor since 2006.
some of my detectives in the background
somewhere so we worked a lot of
uh gruesome cases i i mean if
uh let's that's so many of them you can
go into a scene and you can see it you
can see a body on this side with the
head on that side you know you can go
into a scene where you see our bodies
have been and i hate to start to grow
some scenes it's something you don't see
at a funeral home in the casket what
these detectives out there see on a
normal basis you you can go on a scene
and you can see a body that's been the
person been murdered been in the house
for years for months in the summer time
and everybody's covered with all kinds
of um
i don't hate you know
so and then as you try to get that body
get that person out of the house
that that person's been in the house so
long
body explodes so you see things like
that out there you see a lot of stuff
and sometimes and me being a homicide
supervisor i got to keep an eye on my
detectives sometimes because a lot of
times
my not mentioning names i had to send
some of my detectives to to counseling
because i gotta look at them and see
after we come from a homicide i think
are they okay the detectives in in that
i will mention their names i have
personally had to send to a counselor
saying i noticed that there wasn't
acting right after scene so it affected
detectives too as well as um
um people who see these things for the
first time on these scenes
all right so just just so we don't end
on
such a gloomy note you had one question
do you had a question um oh i did
i wanted to know how the media has
responded to the book
um have you been able to get coverage or
i'm curious to know well we had we've
had a review
and um we actually um luke broadwater
from the bee who i think is here
somewhere right now he was here
he's back there uh was kind enough to
run an excerpt so just without any sort
of uh so you know i think there's been a
um
fairly positive more amongst people you
know i had a woman who called me today
who's been trying to get the book for
three days he's been calling me
personally i don't know how she got my
cell number but you know she's been
trying to track down the book so
truthfully more than a media event i
think there's a lot of people who
personally have have tracked down this
book and been interested in it because i
think you know of what calvin has has
been willing to share something that
people want to really know you know what
is it really like and uh so it's really
been more of a personal
event than a media event like a wire or
something you know we're just we're
going to detail
we've run upstairs on investigative
voice we've had four so far we'll
probably have some more yeah so
investigatorvoice.com
and uh also the book is on sale uh in
the back
and so
we also have a lot of media attention
over in over in the uk as well we got
people that helped we're not supposed to
sell a little book oh yeah we're gonna
make some appearances in that we we're
gonna do a tour of europe yeah that's
true yes we are
okay can i say one other thing all right
um and i said this in the book
um
22 and a half years i've been a
baltimore city police officer a lot of
times uh we're working these these
surrenders cases that's a lot of times i
had to uh
sometimes put my family second to help
to help other families uh get closure in
life and my wife is here tonight she's
sitting she's standing over there i want
to um
[Applause]
yeah thanks for putting up with me for
22 and a half years my two daughters are
back there too thank you ashley yeah and
candace
and
tea is over here who helped me write the
book who is my fiancee
thank you guys very much for coming out
and putting up with the heat uh
though you guys will be glad to sign
copies and continue discussing the book
i'm assuming we have copies of the book
on sale in the back the bar in the back
is open please feel free to browse
around thank you very much and thank you
guys
[Applause]
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on